The strongest one there is.
The largest lawyer in the courtroom.
If the Hulk and She-Hulk threw down, which
green goliath would come out on top?
As we've witnessed through multiple MCU outings,
raw strength does not always determine a winner
in a battle.
Still, it doesn't hurt.
Fans are given an idea of how strong She-Hulk
is relative to regular Hulk when the two powerhouses
go toe-to-toe during the first episode of
"She-Hulk: Attorney at Law."
Bruce Banner, in his Professor Hulk form,
tries to convince his cousin that her new
powers should be used for the good of the
world, but Jennifer isn't interested in becoming a superhero.
An argument ensues, and when Jennifer loses
her temper.
She transforms into She-Hulk and
throws the first punch, initiating her first
superpowered throwdown.
Both Hulks land some big blows during this
fight, with Professor Hulk launching his cousin
through the air and She-Hulk breaking the
Avenger's glasses, which only serves to make
him even angrier.
It's entertaining, but it doesn't give any
definitive answers in terms of strength.
She-Hulk is still new to the whole Hulk thing,
and Professor Hulk is clearly holding back.
Yet, the scene does show that She-Hulk can
at least hold her own against the Avenger,
matching him blow for blow and hurting him
more than once.
She isn't afraid to play a little dirty, stomping
on his foot and even running him over with a car.
Sometimes it takes nimbleness, speed, and
balance to gain the upper hand in a fight.
Unfortunately for Hulk, he's lacking in this
department.
A brute beast, Bruce Banner's alter-ego has
historically relied entirely on his ability
to throw the most brutal punches.
"And, Hulk.
Smash."
Though he has been known to jump from building
to building in the past, Hulk is about as
far from Spider-Man as a hero can be.
She-Hulk does not gain the same lumbering,
musclebound physique as her cousin when she transforms.
Her physicality does improve dramatically,
however, which makes for better reflexes and balance.
As shown during the first episode of "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law," she naturally becomes a
skilled acrobat, quickly outdoing her powerful
relative.
When the two square up, prepared to battle,
Walters appears much more poised and nimbler
than the bulky and lumbering Hulk.
While Banner is a lot faster since his two
personalities merged to become Professor Hulk,
he's nowhere near as nimble as She-Hulk.
Which Hulk has won the most fights?
One would think that this would be no contest
considering Bruce Banner has been smashing
his way through the MCU since 2008.
Unfortunately, Hulk's track record in the
MCU is not quite as good as one would expect.
In fact, audiences have witnessed the big
green monster lose more often than not.
Hulk was convincingly defeated by Thanos in
"Avengers: Infinity War," and before that
he got a beatdown courtesy of Tony Stark and
his Hulkbuster suit in "Avengers: Age of Ultron."
There's also his near loss to the titular
God of Thunder in "Thor: Ragnarok" to consider.
Hulk hasn't really won a superhuman battle
since throwing Loki around like a ragdoll
in 2012's "The Avengers."
She-Hulk is still a rookie contender who doesn't
seem interested in fighting anyone outside
of the courtroom.
Still, in her first real test against Titania
in "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law," she wins easily.
If it weren't for the largely overlooked early
MCU entry "The Incredible Hulk," starring
Edward Norton in the lead role instead of
Mark Ruffalo, the Hulks would have near-equal records.
There is no argument that Bruce Banner is
one of the most intelligent Marvel characters.
A renowned scientist, he casually mentions
to Thor that he has seven PhDs during "Thor: Ragnarok."
Beyond his education, Banner has been an integral
partner to Tony Stark during multiple "Avengers"
movies, assisting in the construction of Ultron
and the time machine utilized in "Avengers: Endgame."
It's not just his post-transformation muscles
that are huge, he arguably has the biggest
brain in the whole MCU.
"Well, if he can do that, he could achieve
heavy ion fusion on any reactor on the planet."
"Finally, someone who speaks English."
"Is that what just happened?"
However, as Jennifer Walters states early
in "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law," Banner is
"not the only genius in the family."
A highly competent lawyer, Walters may not
have the credentials that her cousin boasts,
but she knows the law like the back of her
big green hand and can more than hold her
own in a courtroom.
Walters consistently takes clever jabs at
Banner and his alter-ego, proving that her
wit is a match for his.
As her MCU series proves, She-Hulk often comes
out on top when arguing with her cousin.
A significant factor that deserves consideration
is who a combatant has in their corner.
Iron Man would have never beaten Thanos without
the help of the Avengers.
Spider-Man could not have defeated Norman
Osborn without…Spider-Man.
And even a Hulk needs backup once in a while.
When it comes to Hulk versus She-Hulk, it's
doubtful that any MCU heroes would put themselves
in the middle of a family dispute.
However, a good ally is always worth having
in your corner.
In the comics, She-Hulk easily wins the friendship
round, being the ally and resident attorney
of many Marvel heroes, including the Fantastic
Four and Captain Marvel.
Meanwhile, Hulk has been on the wrong side
of so many heroes that the Illuminati exiled
him from Earth.
It's still early in She-Hulk's MCU career,
but it should be easy for her to make some
superhero friends quickly.
It is already confirmed that characters such
as Wong and Daredevil will appear in "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law."
Meanwhile, the MCU version of Hulk has been
a staple of the Avengers line-up since the
inaugural film in 2012.
While trying to decide who would win in a
fight between She-Hulk and Hulk, it's worth
looking at how a battle between Jennifer Walters
and Bruce Banner would pan out.
Hulk in human form is not much of a combatant.
Unlike other original Avengers, Banner never
gained hand-to-hand combat training and is
often portrayed as a little timid.
Sure, he impressively defeated Cull Obsidian
during "Avengers: Infinity War," but that
fight would not have lasted very long without
Tony Stark's Hulkbuster outfit.
Keeping things equal, Jennifer Walters is
not a highly trained combatant.
She's a successful lawyer dedicated to her
career.
Still, she's much more confident than her
meek scientist cousin.
Based on the relationship showcased in "She-Hulk:
Attorney at Law," we suspect that Walters
regularly came out on top during childhood
familial roughhousing.
And if the two were to fight without their
hulking abilities, there's reason to believe
that Walters would take the win.
If the influx of superhero shows and movies
has proven anything, it's that you need someone
on your super team who packs a mighty punch.
In the comics, a version of the Hulk has often
been part of the Avengers line-up.
In fact, he was part of the very first line-up.
However, deciding who to recruit becomes difficult
when choosing between a raging giant beast
and a composed powerhouse.
In the case of Hulk, he is as strong as they
come and can take on some of the biggest challenges.
Unfortunately, his penchant for flying off
the handle and causing more destruction than
good can become more of a burden than anything
else.
Conversely, She-Hulk is a woman who keeps
her composure, most of the time, at least,
and she can deliver blows of near-equal strength
to her powerful cousin.
Plus, Jennifer Walters has the added bonus
of being an established lawyer.
While it is always nice to have a physicist
around, having someone who can take care of
legal business in your squad certainly sounds
more promising.
Both Hulk and She-Hulk have been part of the
Marvel collection for decades.
She-Hulk first appeared in 1980 with her self-titled
comic book.
Her relation to Bruce Banner helped her quickly
befriend many superheroes and she soon became
a member of teams like the Fantastic Four,
the Avengers, and the Defenders.
She-Hulk became a fan favorite thanks to her
comedy stylings that often featured her breaking
the fourth wall, long before Deadpool made
it cool.
And in the early '90s, there was almost a
She-Hulk movie starring Brigitte Nielsen,
as well as a couple of proposed television
shows.
Alternatively, Hulk was first introduced in
1962 and has remained a shining part of the
Marvel roster since.
The character has become one of the most popular
superheroes globally.
While the word "hulk" predates the Marvel
comics, it has become part of the English
lexicon for someone losing control of their
temper, or "hulking out."
Spawning multiple comic titles, TV shows,
movies, video games, and plenty of other merchandise,
the original comic series "The Incredible
Hulk" has hundreds of issues.
While She-Hulk has some clout, she will always
be a variant of the original and may never
reach the same level of popularity.
In a fight between She-Hulk and Hulk, this
is the ultimate question: what is more powerful,
pure anger or self-control?
It's this factor that differentiates the two
combatants.
Hulk is a synonym for rage.
It is his anger that not only triggers his
monstrous transformation but fuels him during battle.
Not often explored in the MCU, Hulk's strength
is basically limitless, as the angrier he
is, the stronger he gets.
"I know, I'm sorry, I just get so angry all
the time.
Hulk always…
Hulk always angry."
On the other hand, She-Hulk has similar capabilities,
and her rage can cause her to become more dangerous.
However, the fact that Jennifer Walters has
more control over her alter ego arguably makes
her a more formidable warrior.
As is pointed out during the first episode
of "She-Hulk: Attorney at Law," being a woman
probably puts Walters leagues ahead of Banner
in the self-control department.
"Triggers are anger and fear."
"Those are like the baseline of any woman just existing."
Where Hulk can fly off the handle and become
an unstoppable beast with near-unparalleled
strength, She-Hulk has the patience and capability
to remain at the steering wheel.
Of course, she can also become a total rage
monster, but she has more choice in the matter.
Being able to maintain a cool head in a fight
against her rash and unruly cousin might just
be the deciding factor.
Inarguably, one of the best toe-to-toe throwdowns
in the history of the MCU is Hulk versus Thanos
in "Avengers: Infinity War."
The fight highlighted just how powerful the
purple foe was while causing such damage to
Hulk's ego that it took years for the mean,
green fighting machine to recuperate.
That's why Bruce Banner had to use the Hulkbuster
armor to fight Cull Obsidian later in the movie.
The Hulk refused to surface.
But what if it had been She-Hulk aboard that
Asgardian ship as opposed to her cousin?
Would the result have been any different?
As seen in "Avengers: Endgame," female heroes
have fared much better than their male counterparts
when facing Thanos.
Scarlet Witch and Captain Marvel both held
their own against The Mad Titan.
Just like her cousin, She-Hulk would have
no doubt managed to get in some strong blows
using the element of surprise.
Unfortunately, Thanos is just too powerful
to be defeated by any one Avenger alone.
Walters would have likely suffered the same
dreadful beating the Hulk took, although she
may have been aware enough to avoid the one-on-one
fight altogether.
The real question should be: Would She-Hulk
have been capable of donning the Infinity
Gauntlet and performing the same snap her
cousin did, bringing back half of the universe's occupants?
She has the blood of the Hulk pumping through
her veins, so there's nothing to say that
she couldn't withstand such a thing.
Hulk versus She-Hulk would no doubt be a battle
for the ages, a real drop-down drag out of
a fight that nobody would forget in a hurry.
The hits and destruction would probably resemble
the intense bout between Hulk and Thor in "Thor: Ragnarok."
However, it's safe to say that this fight
would be much more personal.
Whatever caused these combatants to throw
blows would no longer matter in the heat of
the moment, as each would want to prove that
they are the strongest Hulk there is.
She-Hulk would use her wits, her speed, and
her mobility to gain a strategic advantage
over her enormous cousin.
Her more agile frame would allow her to dodge
the Hulk's powerful but easily telegraphed attacks.
Still, it only takes one of those blows to
land, and the longer the fight went on, the
angrier, and therefore stronger, the Hulk
would become.
While his blows would be slower and fewer,
they would land much harder.
On top of that, Bruce Banner's alter ego surely
remembers the embarrassment served to him
at the hands of Thanos.
The Hulk would not want to lose another big
fight, especially to his newcomer cousin.
As impressive as She-Hulk is she would have
a hard time keeping the Hulk down.